we begin in Israel where Business
Leaders have warned that the country's
new right-wing government could deal a
blow to the country's tech industry
they're concerned about appointments
such as Finance Minister betzel smorrich
who is the head of the far-right process
of religious Zionism party in a recent
letter sent to prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu hundreds of tech leaders and
investors maintained that new laws
eroding minority rights and limiting the
independence of the Judiciary could
deter investors and quote undermine
confidence in Israeli democracy
he's the founder and CEO of I8 Ventures
a platform focused on Innovation yes
good to see you please can you tell me
why is the tech industry so worried
about this new government
well um thanks for having me and thanks
for taking upon this uh very important
issue we are a very small country we are
extremely dependent on the high-tech
industry
and the high-tech industry by its nature
is a global industry we are extremely
excited about open ideas we are
extremely excited about selling things
to the world if the government is too
focused on insular and small issues and
this religious issue or that religious
issue it's a full-blown conflict with
the sector that is actually paying for
everything here in Israel so the tension
is rising
okay but on that note how realistic do
you think these concerns are about a
corporate Exodus could we really be
seeing this
absolutely it's it's very easy you know
it's not factories it's people I am sure
many of the companies here in Israel
both the Israeli companies and the
international uh firms that have r d
centers in Israel have a folder which
says living Israel I'm sure of it and if
the government of Israel is not careful
enough and again it's not because they
don't like Israel just that they're
going to make a decision why why make
life so complicated we can move things
uh into places and people will move you
know the Jews are very good at moving so
uh I think the government really needs
to pay attention to this
okay so obviously a huge number of
issues going on around here um Israel's
Tech sector is of course a very
important engine of growth
um how is prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu responding to these concerns
I am sure he is well aware of these
issues he was one of the people that
instigated and created the high-tech
sector in Israel and I'm actually sure
that he will worry about this and make
sure we may not hear it out loud because
of politics but I'm 100 sure that it's
on top of his mind to maintain the
balance between the local issues and the
government is really right wing and the
global interest which are the key for
the success of the high-tech industry in
Israel
okay so it does look like business and
politics are on a collision course there
yes just even thank you very much
thank you very much great to be here
with you thank you